hey guys I'm Ryan right so today we're
gonna learn 16 knotty facts about sex I
found this video because it's it just
fits in tune with the rest of the you
know the channel whatever that means
let's watch this Ariana okay it's good
to know she likes like seven these days
the Greeks have more sex than any other
nationality not true there are roughly
100 million acts of sexual intercourse
each day you kind of participate in half
of them in 2005 a couple bros a world
record for the longest unbroken kiss
[Music]
side seam in Japan on both ships and
dolphins are the only animals of sexual
pleasure I know this from personal
experience
[Music]
it is Anne Hathaway telling a convincing
lie to someone is much more difficult
when you find them sexually attractive
that's true what do humans fish and
porpoises have in common they all have
oral sex under half a man think their
penis is too small whereas 85% of women
are very sized with their partner's
penis size the average amount of time
spent kissing for a person in the
lifetime is 26 average healthy man
produces approximately 300 million sperm
and just a teaspoon of Essene yes one
little swimmer to fertilize a woman's
egg that's so scary 2003 a pair of male
Penguins in Central Park Zoo have been a
couple for years greater than being all
[Music]
average speed of ejaculation 20 mine's
more like 75 miles per hour the black
widow spider eats her mate during or
after sex Oh
as many as 20 lover oh my god it sounds
like this single sperm contains 37 point
5 megabytes of DNA information wow
that's a lot of information I will never
remember 62 matters Wow Wow
some interesting facts you burn about
200 calories during 30 minutes of active
sex not many calories it doesn't seem
like a lot of calories like when I do
the elliptical McDonald's cone I know
you got to think about like what is 200
calories and it's like a couple of
french fries [ __ ] yeah is that
assuming like you're on top for most of
the year constantly not because what if
the girls just thought sorry she's right
it's a long time it is to be actively
doing something what if you're like so
into it I mean that he already came
before so now you're going and you just
just keep going it's funny sometimes I
feel like I get a workout from it gets
my core with all the humping really for
yoga for you like you would be like a
freak not afraid I know you always try
to position me as some kind of position
you mm I have a girlfriend I can't make
that joke the average penis size is 3.5
to 3.7 inches when flattened and between
five point zero two five and point seven
interesting interesting
are you satisfied with that size show me
five point seven inches well no I'm not
a person Oh like what this banana yeah I
don't know you don't know if that would
be a good enough well it's a computer
and this the size matter to you I don't
think these are appropriate I'm not
answering any of them what the hell okay
I was of course it's not appropriate I
was starting my career
these things out there though I started
my career they have a fact you're saying
that like under half of men think that
their penis sizes to us women are very
satisfied I do believe that like I think
a lot of guys are very penis size
there's a lot of others on what I hear
is that there's actually more women who
are unsatisfied with the big penis cuz
that can actually hurt yeah yeah as
opposed to it's okay it's weird because
men are like oh I'm so masculine because
of how big I was like this one guy and
he was like this one girl broke up with
me so so big that happens I know yeah
whatever you got you could work with it
thanks Arianna you're like Oprah
inspiring today Greeks have more sex
than any other nationality because the
Greeks I feel like we're a lot more
fluid with like orgies and being gay oh
yeah they started says yeah no one was
having sex until the Greeks giggle yeah
there are roughly 100 million acts of
sexual inner well there's billions of
people have to do statistically how many
here above ages I actually missed this
sentence the longest unbroken kiss was
31 hours 30 minutes and 30 they loved
everything it was an Israel I really
feel like I've read this longest
unbroken kiss man I'd like an unbroken
kiss for ten minutes seems nice to walk
you to the bathroom so you can pee
during that 30 31 hours you have that's
a whole that's more than a dollar a day
the hell kisses for over it like what
does the thing is Israelis it was it
just to win the contest yes I mean no we
don't have time I hate the idea of fish
if you have the idea of fish why I
cannot stand fish they terrify me well
we know you don't smell like fish down
there sorry I will try to cut back
that's jokes like I've known you for so
long if I knew you before I even ever
had my period and somehow all you can do
is be inappropriate
I'm sorry the average healthy man
produces approximately 300 million sperm
that is scary to know how just one okay
so even if one's over that seriously no
one does I take it very serious Ariana
does even with a condom and birth
control if you come in a girl there's
still a chance I'm in a girl if you're
wearing a condom what do you mean what
if well if you'll come in the carnival
you can be inside the point okay so it's
a 99.9 percent act like with the condom
and then there's like a 99.9 percent
with birth control so it's very unlikely
unless a kind of rape and then your only
difference like it could still I know
one person who was formed from that and
strangely she knows it's him she must
have a disturbance control like she
works in pharmaceutical so I knew a lot
about I only know things about sex in a
not sexy way you know what I mean it was
all very like medical and dangerous oh
no wonder you're so comfortable with it
so addicted to it yep that's right
sex addict and I'm here to help sex
addicts overcome their addiction by
making fun happens she's not a sex
addict guys at least that means have
committed average speed of ejaculation
28 miles were lying all these things
that's fast what do you do i infections
from things like this from like having
come on there I shot into it oh man
really
don't imagine woman epic cocky parties
man oh I'm glad you asked a [ __ ]
party can mainly consist of like on
average about 10 to 30 guys sometimes
it's tough like 50 where they're all
jerking off and they all come sometimes
I have sex with everybody usually they
just huh they come on this one girl and
they usually come on her face times they
come all in a stop and then she drinks
it
it's like [ __ ] worshipping it's hot I
participated in many but it's a real
thing yeah do they pay the girl she's
like a prostitute I'm sorry dude I don't
know how things like do cockys and
gangbangs get arranged just like the
girls just blowing the guy you just walk
around is very I don't know why he was
shy never mind it's good well worth it I
like how I talk about Brandon everyone
settle on this chair nobody's ever
yeah well yeah I mean those are some fun
facts rather read them we could have
just read them I mean I could have been
a list it could have been a list and we
just decided which ones to talk about
but it wouldn't be a video reaction now
Twitter Ariana was that much of a video
yes it was it wasn't her photos whose a
slideshow was a glorified slideshow
anyway guys thanks for tuning in if
you're new to the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects and you
can check out Ariana's channel brand new
videos going up check it out you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram and
Twitter where if we get enough followers
product placement vehicle so we can get
product placement for things like what
brand is that person Tory Burch what
Tory Burch Tory Burch Tory Burch bags
all right burn Tory Burch bags Tory
Burch bags are great they hold
everything they're beautiful to look at
and they can hold many things like let's
look inside here oh you don't want to do
that okay so I see tampons condoms
dildos many vibrators an actual cutoff
human black [ __ ] yes
one human black penis a human one that's
real none of you can believe anything
right chapstick just I forgot the name
of the bag over to get sponsorship from